it sounded like you were being critical
of jay-z's last album i turning it but
you called his last album golf course
music I mean so just now's your time to
explain no no look hip-hop coach is
connected to you of culture right yeah
now you see the closes grown man stuff
going on right yeah you know like the
kids gonna bring new innovative stuff
and then he just had the maturity bled
off into the material so you look and
you go it's cool for me like in my car
I'm listening to it but the kids I don't
see them actually listening if you
thought that he was getting like a
little bit sort of high society a little
yeah a little like he was like talking
down at him right like a little bit like
I'm up here baby right so have you
talked to him about this yet no I
haven't had a conversation that's how I
feel yeah yeah yeah golf course music I
heard that and I think I didn't really
know that they play you know like
hip-hop
I felt like Carlton banks like when I
was listening to the problem you mean
from Fresh Prince yeah yeah what was his
dance I forget what was but he just felt
so weird like I can't remember his dance
can you no I ain't doing that Duke
[Applause]
you